We can find the answer to this question right within our environment.
We first just run the initialization--that is just passing a string in here and we just run
and nothing happens, no error message, so this is just fine.
It's actually possible to pass a string object here.
Now, when we try to print it out and run this whole thing, we get an error message
because now what we have is that the format up here is no longer appropriate
for an object of type string--that is Python does not know how to format a string
with two digits with a leading zero.
As you see, as soon as we are printing out the object, we get an error
and therefore, the correct answer here is we get an error while printing.